suponemos que tenemos una cuadrícula de
6 x 6 y eso es lo que está dibujado ahí
1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 y vamos a
empezar arriba a la izquierda donde
estamos dibujando una s y el chiste es
llegar abajo a la derecha donde estamos
dibujando una estrella
y uno solo se puede mover en dos
direcciones uno solo se puede mover a la
derecha o hacia abajo pero
definitivamente no nos podemos ver en
diagonal no nos pongo a ver hacia arriba
y no nos pueden mover hacia la izquierda
así es que en cada paso que demos nos
vamos a estar acercando un poquito más
hacia la estrella no nos podemos hacer
hacia atrás y me pregunta para ti eres
de cuántas formas distintas nos podemos
ir de la s a la estrella cuántos caminos
distintos hay esa es la del problema
entonces le puedes poner pausa y tratar
de resolverlo y después cuando le quites
la pausa vamos a ver paso por paso la
solución le puedes poner pausa en
cualquier paso intermedio y ver los
pasos como pistas también y bueno
podemos empezar digamos viendo de
cuántas formas podemos ir de la s a cada
cuadrado en medio y eso nos va a ayudar
un poco a ver cuántos caminos hay hasta
la de la deseada la estrella cambiamos
de color de cuántas formas podemos ir de
la s al cuadrado de la derecha
pues solo nos podemos ir de una forma no
se podemos seguir de la s a la derecha y
ya estamos en el cuadrado
hay una forma
y para el cuadro de abajo tenemos lo
mismo solo podemos irnos de arriba hacia
abajo entonces hay una única forma hay
que recordar que no pronunciar la
derecha después hacia abajo y luego
hacia la izquierda porque irá hacia la
izquierda nos aleja de la estrella y no
podemos hacer eso es uno de los pasos
prohibidos no entonces pero bueno de
cuántas formas podemos ir a esta otra
celda pues podemos ir a la derecha y
luego otra vez a la derecha y ya es la
ule el único camino que hay si vamos
hacia abajo no vamos a poder regresar
hacia arriba entonces hay una única
forma
y lo mismo pasa por para todos esos
cuadrados de arriba
podemos hacer el mismo tipo de
pensamiento para los cuadrados de la
izquierda así y entonces solo podemos ir
por caminos que vayan directamente hacia
abajo y hay una forma para cada uno de
esos cuadrados pero bueno veamos algo un
poquito más interesante cuántas formas
hay que llegar a ese cuadrado que
estamos pintando de verde en estos
momentos pues lo primero que podemos
hacer es ir hacia abajo y luego hacia la
derecha o hacia la derecha y luego hacia
abajo y entonces pues podemos ver que
hay dos caminos para llegar a ese
cuadrado
pero pues estuvo muy fácil porque anda
más cuatro cuadrados pero ya podemos
empezar a ver un patrón no dibujemos
allí un cuadrado
y dibujemos otro cuadrado no eso no lo
quiere hacer mejor dibujemos luego así
y dibujemos lo así
y digamos que son cuales queda tres
cuadrados en nuestra cuadrícula de 6 x 6
realidad no tiene que ser una cuadrícula
de 6 x 6 puede ser una cuadrícula de 100
por 100 pero no tardaremos demasiado en
hacer las cuentas supongamos que
queremos encontrar cuántas formas hay
cuántos caminos hay de llegar a este
lugar
si hay n n caminos que llegan al cuadro
de arriba y hay m caminos que llegan al
quad de la izquierda entonces bueno la
única forma de llegar a ese cuadrado que
ahora vamos a señalar con blanco la
única forma de llegar a ese cuadrado
yendo solo hacia abajo o solo hacia la
derecha es llegar al cuadrado de arriba
y luego bajar o llegar al cuadro de la
izquierda y luego ir a la derecha
entonces de cuántas formas congrega ahí
pues la única forma es ver cuántos
caminos llegan al cuadrado de arriba y
la misma cantidad de caminos que llegan
al codo arriba van a ser la misma
cantidad de caminos que lleguen al codo
arriba y luego bajen porque pues nada
más estamos bajando
y lo mismo sucede desde la izquierda
entonces para llegar a este cuadrado
que es la celda que es lo mismo hay n
más m formas de llegar enemas m caminos
espero que lo hayan entendido no hay dos
formas de llegar desde arriba o desde la
izquierda y hay n formas de llegar desde
arriba
y porque sólo hay una forma de llegar al
algo de arriba y hay formas de llegar al
cuadrado de la izquierda
veamos si esto que acabamos de ver
funciona porque no lo podemos tomar así
nada más como axioma de fe y tiene que
tener sentido para ti cuántas formas hay
del grave según lo que acabamos de ver
deberíamos de nada más sumar dos más uno
y nos quedan tres
veamos si funciona podemos ir siempre a
la derecha y luego hacia abajo o ponzio
a la derecha abajo ya la derecha o
pueden seguir el tercer camino abajo y
luego a la derecha y ya y ahora ve de
las tres formas para llegar allí una
viene desde arriba y dos vienen desde la
izquierda lo cual tiene sentido de
acuerdo a lo que acabamos de ver no es
bueno vamos a llenar toda la caja a ver
ese es uno dos tres que también también
luego vamos a cambiar de color para ser
un poquito más interesante 13 son 4 33
16 31 son 4
y pues ya podemos empezar una simetría
en esa diagonal hay 3 y un 3 hay un 4 en
4 están los turnos se han visto los
videos de los coeficientes binomial eso
el triángulo de pascal deberían de
empezar a reconocer algunas cantidades
ahí hay un 5 este cuando tiene un montón
de cosas curiosas tienen los unos tiene
del 1 al 6 1 2 3 4 5 6
64 16/04/2010 10 5 15 21 20 15 25 21 35
35 70 35 21 son 56
35 21.56 156
60 70 son 126 126 y finalmente 126 más
126 son 252 que vamos a escribirlo con
un color especial entonces hay 252
formas 252 caminos
que van de ese a la estrella de hecho
pudimos haber hecho esto para cualquier
cuadrícula podría ser por ejemplo una
vez 5 x 4 y nos quedaría 35
ahora para hacerlo a mano o sea allí ver
camino por camino te habrías tardado
años
bueno no años pero mucho hay algo muy
interesante aquí si si viste el vídeo
los coeficientes binomial es reconocerás
que estos son los coeficientes binomial
es así es que bueno déjame dibujar algo
aquí por cierto esto es algo extra ya
resolvimos el problema si tu único
objetivo era resolverlo y no ver cómo se
conecta con otras cosas de matemáticas
pues dejar de ver el vídeo aquí pero te
voy a enseñar algo muy interesante si
queremos encontrar la potencia n de x +
d
hacemos esto mucho en los vídeos de los
coeficientes binomial es y el triángulo
pascal pero quiero que veas que es
exactamente lo mismo de hecho podría ser
más fácil para ti que usa el triángulo
de pascal aunque esencialmente es lo
mismo si escribimos arriba 1 x x
cuadrada
bueno aquí x cuadrada no se ve muy bien
x la 3x a la 4 x a las 5 se supone que
van arriba al cuadrado pero pues ni modo
al cuadrado y al cubo
llegué a las 5
y si yo quisiera encontrar dado todo
esto cuál es x más a la no sé a la 4
bueno lo que podemos hacer es ok bueno
ya sabemos que es x a la 4 más un montón
de términos más que a la 4 y todo ello
en medio decimos bueno o equis a la 4 y
justo hasta la 4 y bueno vamos a ver ver
esta diagonal de aquí en medio entonces
esta diagonal de aquí pues esta diagonal
nos va a decir cuál son los coeficientes
y no sólo no va a decir los coeficientes
nos va a decir cuál es la mezcla de los
coeficientes a ver a qué me refiero con
esto bueno primero tenemos que borrar un
poco cosas
esto es extra al problema ya resolvimos
el problema
entonces bueno si quieren ver cuáles x
más ya la 4 lo único que tenemos que
hacer es bueno después nos va a dejar
jugar un poco con este cuadrado para que
vean todas las cosas curiosas que tienen
las diagonales pero si quieren ver
cuáles x más real a 4 primero vemos que
es x a la 4 x 1
1 x l 4 x 1
+ 4 x 3
por qué
y eso es justo ese con s + 6 x al
cuadrado porque al cuadrado y x al
cuadrado y al cuadrado
+ 4x
por tres y luego al fin el 1 y el 4 por
y podrían decir es este maravilloso
porque funciona y bueno la forma de
pensar lo es cuando multiplica x + ya la
4 y les recomiendo que lo intenten un
día que estén aburridos pues hay 6
formas de obtener un término de estos x
cuadrada por ye cuadrada lo verán cuando
multipliquen los términos lo explicamos
en la parte de intuición de los vídeos
del teorema del binomio y hay seis
formas de llegar a este término lo cual
es exactamente la pregunta de cuántas
formas hay de llegar a este cuadrado y
como ya vimos 66 bueno espero que lo
hayan disfrutado un poco